he's David Ayres the Hurricanes
emergency goalie got the wind the ripe
old age of 42 David how you feeling
today a little tired I feel good all
right if I told you a week ago hey by
the way you're gonna make your NHL debut
coming up in a week and you're not going
to be playing for Toronto the team that
employs you you're gonna be playing for
the Carolina Hurricanes what would you
say I would say I'll take that any day
you know just a chance to get out on the
ice and make a couple saves it doesn't
matter who who it is I would love to get
out there but the Hurricanes were
fantastic these guys were amazing
everybody that I've met in the
organization it's been unreal and I'm
excited to get to rally to see you bunch
of the guys and watch a game okay but
I'm just trying to understand trying to
wrap my head around it the home team has
to have that emergency backup to the
backup goaltender and that's you so you
could have played for Toronto if there
were injuries now you're going against
Toronto and you're gonna play for
Carolina and then you let the first two
goals in and I thought oh no you can't
have this he's he's employed by Toronto
what did he did any of the players say
hey David at least go through the
motions here act like a goalie this is
not cool you know we kind of want to
smack myself upside the head and wake up
a little bit but the players were good
they just came up to me and said relax
and take it easy and mate just you know
have fun make some saves and they played
great in front of me and we ended up
pulling through in the third period and
a good win but you're not the Maple
Leafs Zamboni driver you haven't
graduated to that you're right you're
the AHL did the Toronto Marlies you're
their Zamboni driver yeah so I've driven
four leaves before a few years back and
I actually haven't driven for the
Marley's in the past five five and a
half years so the whole Zamboni thing is
kind of old now I I Drive maybe once a
week just to keep my skills glow but I'm
at the old Naples Gardens madami
Athletic Center and that's the
operations manager there so I've got a
really good building operators they
drive the Zamboni and I kind of taught
them what I know and they hold down the
fort for me
so I can go out there and make a few
saves but are you the emergency Zamboni
driver for the maple leaves no
definitely not but I wouldn't turn that
one down either that's pretty fun I've
done it once though it was pretty cool
are you a better Zamboni driver or
goalie oh if you look at my performance
the other day definitely were gonna say
better Zamboni job everybody
I've been doing that long long time 216
years driving the Zamboni so but I like
to still think I can make a save here
and there uh how good were you at your
peak as a goaltender uh you know I was
probably practicing with the Marley's
when I started in like my early 30min
thirties and I felt like I was I was
pretty good and I was on the ice a lot
with those guys so obviously you want to
get 40 your body doesn't feel like it
did you know 10 years ago so I can still
make saves I just can't move as fast let
you feel at ease when did you get the
word like who gives you the word that
Carolina needs you as their goaltender
where are you in the building yes I just
was half dressed
well I was standing in the building
first just my dress clothes and my
equipment was actually down in my truck
and they just one of the nice guys calls
me and said you know let's go let's get
down here the goalie got hurt and it's
all you get half of my equipment on and
kind of sit there and watch the game and
then the other goalie goes down and
that's when you get the nod to put the
rest of your here on and get in there do
you have to introduce yourself no no not
really I I know a lot of the people are
there right so it was good
how much you get paid for that
performance it was a big zero weight a
lot of memories that's for sure wait I
was told you got $500 and you got to
keep your Jersey yeah that's I come in
Jersey for sure I got that my Jersey the
park they took my stick to the Hockey
Hall of Fame
but money-wise you know the money is not
a thing it's the memories as what I'll
take away from it well wait what's the
league minimum for one game David I'm
gonna fight for you here I know I need
to find that out it's just so weird to
see you in a Carolina
your uniform and you go into the locker
room with Carolina and you're employed
by Toronto it's just like it's you know
it's one of those great things about
hockey that you're a hockey player and
my best I'll give you my best no matter
whose team I'm on because that's what
I'm supposed to do that's exactly and I
said that already today it's that's the
hockey community you know the guys will
welcome you as long as you're on their
team they're gonna welcome you and
they're gonna play hard for you and I
try to do the same thing for them so
4240 done can you do the splits I can
can you get back up after you do yes
Paulie we had the league minimum for the
NHL and we did the math we had people we
know do the math okay he should have
made about 900 bucks for the fill in
shift based off the league minimum
salary you look at that you let me push
this David a little bit
I can talk to Bettman and and get you I
mean no one to turn out 900 yeah that's
true
the memories are worth it the awesome
hey it was fun to watch David and can't
imagine how nervous you were like you
let the first two in in that next shot
oh my god I think everybody had to be
holding they even Toronto fans had to be
going oh god I hope he stops one of
these yeah I know I had a couple of
buddies at the game so they would have
been all over me if I let three in a row
and I probably would've got pulled at
that point they would have just had an
empty net I think that David
congratulations wonderful story thank
you very much I appreciate it that's
David Ayers
the hurricanes emergency goalie for more
Dan Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]